pour les uns c'est une dictature qui ne
dit pas son nom pour les autres une
démocratie socialiste qui montre une
autre voie possible certains disent le
régime à bout de souffle au bord de
l'implosion et de la guerre civile
quelle est la réalité que se passe-t-il
au venezuela
ce matin dans le centre de caracas une
immense manifestation est organisée en
l'honneur du président nicolas maduro
saluons les travailleurs du venezuela
camarades nous sommes tous frères
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
sourire aux lèvres venu soutenir
l'héritier politique d'hugo chavez
[Musique]
aucune caméra étrangère n'est présente
nous ne posons pas de question pour
éviter d'attirer l'attention des membres
du service de sécurité
ils patrouillaient à moto appuyés par
des militaires qui se sont glissés au
milieu de la foule
[Musique]
ces militants sont aujourd'hui le visage
de la révolution bolivarienne
[Musique]
je t'avais et vive maduro
livre l'indépendance socialiste la
république bolivarienne
[Musique]
ce matin la capitale appartient ce que
l'on appelle les chavistes et les
soutiens du gouvernement
ils clament leur victoire après
plusieurs semaines d'affrontements
[Musique]
deux camps se sont opposés dans les rues
de caracas
violemment
des scènes de guerre civile policiers
contre protestataires plus de 120
personnes tuées de part et d'autre
et des blessés qui se comptent par
centaines
ces manifestants d'opposition dénoncent
l'autoritarisme du président nicolas
maduro qui les accusent d'être
responsable de la pire crise économique
que le pays ait jamais connue
partout dans caracas aujourd'hui des
files d'attentes pour acheter de la
nourriture le
pays manque de tout la pénurie est
criante et visibles les pharmacies sont
vides impossible aujourd'hui de trouver
des antibiotiques
l'inflation est vertigineuse plus de 800
% en un an et la monnaie le bolivar ne
vaut plus rien voici ce que représente
50 euros changent et au marché noir
à notre arrivée dans la capitale
omniprésent fin sur tous les murs le
regard de l'ancien président hugo chavez
les militaires quadrillent la ville
nous allons passer quinze jours dans
cette capitale réputée la plus
dangereuse au monde 4000 homicide rien
que l'année dernière pour rencontrer
ceux qui croient encore dans les idéaux
de chavez ce qui soutient envers et
contre tous son héritier nicolas maduro
en immersion avec les irréductibles du
régime mais aussi ceux qui en sont
revenus
ce matin nous avons rendez vous dans un
quartier des hauteurs de caracas elle
trompe quito cette petite municipalité
est impatiente chavistes un quartier où
jamais la presse ne s'est rendu pour y
entrer nous avons obtenu l'accord de cet
homme grégory c'est le chef d'un
colectivo une milice populaire pro
gouvernementales ne vous inquiétez pas
vous pouvez me faire confiance et à mes
hommes aussi tout le monde ici est bien
discipliné dans le quartier allez on y
va suivez-moi
cet ancien chauffeur livreur père de
deux enfants gère une trentaine d'hommes
s'il a accepté de nous laisser
l'accompagné c'est pour nous montrer
comment ils assurent la sécurité du
quartier le maintien de l'ordre
et comment ils vérifient que personne ne
porte d'armes
ici il a le droit de fouiller n'importe
qui des contrôles aléatoires alors qu'il
n'est pas policier
montrez nous ce que vous avez dans vos
sacs et sortez vos papiers
vous savez qu'il ya des mecs qui volent
là bas plus haut oui vous devriez faire
gaffe
ces collectifs de citoyens armés ont été
créées à l'initiative du président
maduro pour éradiquer la criminalité qui
sévit dans les quartiers pauvres
ici sur cette route il y a énormément de
vols de motos de téléphone les
délinquants arrêtés passant les bras
qu'avec une arme et vole tous ceux qui
passent donc nos patrouilles pour tenter
de les prendre en flagrant délit après
on avise soit les mecs se défendent et
on fait ce qu'on peut soit on arrive à
les arrêter alors on les livre aux
autorités compétentes
en fait vous travailler main dans la
main avec la police
oui on se coordonne avec la garde
nationale la police on est bien organisé
et on s'entraide si on a besoin d'armes
il nous en prêtent
ils portent cet insigne du ministère de
l'intérieur pour ne pas être confondus
avec les délinquants leurs armes sont
cachés dans leur sacoche
les quartier populaire de caracas vivent
aujourd'hui sous la coupe de ses
miliciens
bon les gars quand on avance je veux
toujours quelqu'un devant et un autre
qui regarde derrière pour l'instant vous
ne sortez pas vos armes parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde dans les rues et je
n'aime pas attirer l'attention
et vous les journalistes restés bien
collé à nous
chaque conseil municipal à des listes
avec les noms de tous les habitants
grâce à ça les gens reçoivent de l'aide
alimentaire et bénéficient des services
sociaux les conseils ont des
informations sur tout le monde et ils
savent qui se comporte mal qui vole qui
assassine
alors ils nous passent les
renseignements et c'est là que nous
intervenons on procède à l'extraction de
la personne en question on se met en
contact avec les autorités pour qu'il
soit présenté à la justice
le problème c'est que souvent les
criminels résiste ne veulent pas se
faire arrêter et nous on est obligé de
les tuer s'il meurt c'est parce qu'ils
s'opposent à nous
les blés ma mais toi contre le mur et
vite
qu'est ce que tu fais ici toi allez
écarte les jambes tu viens d'où comme ça
au quartier en bas il fait quoi ici là
tu viens faire quoi
poncin yachts et barrez vous sauve après
en courant et tu m'as pas vu hockey
amateur femme et toi mc oui toi reste où
tu es dans ce quartier tout le monde
doit se soumettre à ces contrôles
aléatoires la ville émard et ta chemise
et vous derrière là je veux plus vous
voir filer
les personnes ne sont elles aussi
opposées taqwa dans tes poches mais
clemmons téléphone comme s'il était
devenu une habitude tu habites ou au
panorama
malaisie - demoiselle
allez-y madame
si on doit tout contrôler tous les
jeunes qui ont l'air suspect on vérifie
pour moi tout le monde est suspect
personne est innocent
ces derniers mois ces milices se sont
taillé une sombre réputation
l'opposition a dénoncé leurs exactions
durant les manifestations
vous avez participé aux manifestations
en renfort
exactement et on est obligés d'employer
la force encore plus que la guerre
nationale et en essayant de n'agresser
personne mais quand ceux d'en face nous
tirent dessus avec des armes
nous sommes obligés de répliquer et nous
défendre d'une manière ou d'une autre
habillée au civil mêlés à la foule ces
milices ont appuyé les forces de l'ordre
provoquant la terreur dans les rangs des
manifestants
c'est la face invisible des
affrontements qui explique aussi leur
violence
au cocktail molotov répondent les tirs
tendus des forces de l'ordre des
grenades lacrymogènes des balles en
caoutchouc
et même les tirs à balles réelles
[Musique]
depuis ces groupes de miliciens ont
réinvesti les quartiers prêts à
intervenir de nouveau si on leur demande
grégory et ses hommes sont tous des
chavistes de la première heure
il apporte aujourd'hui un soutien sans
faille au président maduro
ça a été compliqué très compliqué pour
maduro après la mort du commandant
chavez
parce que beaucoup de monde s'est dressé
contre lui
et il a dû affronter une opposition très
puissante qui était bien décidé à le
faire tomber
moi j'ai voté dès le début pour chavez
après le coup d'état parce que je
voulais un changement dans le pays il y
avait trop de répression c'était
n'importe quoi le commandant apporter
une nouvelle vision de nouveaux idéaux
il a fait une révolution en donnant le
pouvoir au peuple le peuple a conquis un
pouvoir qu'il n'avait jamais eu
auparavant
soul chaves l'état a largement investi
dans des programmes sociaux de logement
de santé et de transport
profitant de l'embellie des prix du
pétrole dont le pays possède les plus
grandes réserves au monde
hugo chavez lui même voulait faire de
son pays un exemple de démocratie
socialiste pour le monde entier
nous vivons dans un monde où règne le
pessimisme les forces négatives les
menacent la sécurité et la fin
la fin au monde dans le monde mais au
venezuela elle diminue la pauvreté
augmente dans le monde mais au venezuela
elle diminue cela ne rend pas fier cela
nous oblige à travailler davantage pour
ne pas échouer
neuf ans après cette déclaration chavez
est mort nicolas maduro lui a succédé il
doit faire face aujourd'hui ironie de
l'histoire à une pénurie alimentaire
sans précédent
caracas vite aujourd'hui la faim au
ventre au point que ses habitants
fouillent dans les poubelles
est ce qu'ils ne peuvent dire haut et
fort ils l'écrivent sur les murs de la
ville
maduro assassin
il faut protester
il faut se révolter car on a faim
depuis l'élection de nicolas maduro les
prix du pétrole ont chuté le baril qui
se vendait plus de 120 dollars sous de
chavez vaut aujourd'hui 3 fois moins
cher les caisses sont vides le venezuela
manque cruellement de devises
conséquence le pays qui dépend à plus de
90% des importations n'a plus les moyens
d'acheter à l'étranger de quoi nourrir
sa population
avec l'inflation et le marché noir les
prix ont été multipliés par 100
supermarchés et boucherie ne sont plus
approvisionnées quand on trouve de la
viande le kilo coûte près d'un salaire
minimum l'équivalent de 1000 euros en
france
pour les chavistes tout cela est la
faute de la contrebande et des
entreprises privées qui ne produisent
plus rien en réponse à ces pénuries le
gouvernement a lancé des distributions
de nourriture à prix réduit l'année
dernière
nous sommes restés dans le quartier de
roukn pitot sur les conseils de grégory
pour voir comment s'organisent ces
distributions avec d'autres militants
tous sont membres d'un clap un comité
local d'approvisionnement et de
production
ils sont chargés de distribuer un sac
par mois comme celui ci aux familles à
faible revenu
dix kilos de produits de première
nécessité vendu à nous
il ya du riz du lait pour les enfants
des jus des pâtes tous ces produits sont
fabriqués hors nsu et là des produits
sociale tout est fait en terre
socialiste
ce sont les produits de base de
l'alimentation des vénézuéliens
grâce à cela nous démontrons nous
n'avons pas besoin d'entreprises privées
que le gouvernement vénézuélien peut le
faire grâce aux entreprises d'état
montré bien les détails des produits
tout cela ne coûte que 1 euro
l'explication vire à la leçon de
propagande les aliments sont la fierté
du gouvernement les étiquettes alors que
même les articles de la constitution
il faut que second travail soit vu
partout dans le monde que les gens
sachent qu aujourd'hui venezuela il y à
la paix qu'il voit qu'il est une
révolution en marche ce que l'on veut
ici c'est la patrie nous voulons la
patrie et la patrie nous l'avons chavez
et vivants nous vivrons et nous
vaincrons
et vous faites comment pour savoir qui
distribuait les sacs de nourriture
alors nous donnons le sac pas seulement
aux gens qui sont en faveur du processus
révolutionnaire mais aussi à ceux de
l'opposition ici nous croyons à la
révolution et le processus
révolutionnaire soutient le président
nicolas maduro et je remercie
sincèrement le gouvernement vénézuélien
pour les efforts qu'il fait pour son
peuple
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous venez prendre une photo avec nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les milices gère l'insécurité les
comités de chavistes les distributions
alimentaires
tout est bien réglé en apparence
[Musique]
car la colère monte et la fin échauffe
les esprits
les distributions sont insuffisantes et
trouver à manger chaque jour relève du
parcours du combattant
nous retrouvons grégory et ses hommes
dans le quartier de rookie taux
reculer à reculer s'il vous plaît
reculez une fois que vous avez un numéro
rester bien dans la file depuis 6 heures
du matin une centaine de personnes à
temps pour acheter du pain après un
numéro trois honda par personnes
seulement
c'est la première fois que cette
boulangerie est livrée en farine depuis
une semaine elle a été pillé à plusieurs
reprises ces derniers mois
c'est tous les jours comme cela et
encore s'il ya de la farine en ce moment
la production a baissé mais on nous a
dit qu'elle allait reprendre et quand il
n'y a pas pas franchement là c'est
vraiment dur
au moins les choses s'améliorent
progressivement parce qu'avant on
pouvait rester 15 jours sans farine
en échange de sa protection la milice de
grégory touche un pourcentage des ventes
c'est ainsi qu'elle se finance
et quand on a une famille nombreuse on
fait quoi avec un seul petit sac de pain
je m'en sors pas moi
il est belle et femme au foyer elle vit
avec ses cinq enfants son mari et ses
parents
la situation est chaotique je passe mon
temps à chercher de la nourriture on va
d'un endroit à un autre sans en trouver
suffisamment mais comment je fais moi il
ya plus de farine ni de pâte ni même de
riz et si jamais vous en trouvez c'est
hors de prix
au moins j'ai reçu aujourd'hui acheter
une wii
et
vous gagnez combien pas moi
mon mari gagne 3 euros par semaine et
des tickets d'alimentation et
aujourd'hui on peut rien acheter avec un
paquet de pâtes ou de riz coûte presque
un euro cinquante la moitié de son
salaire
même les supermarchés n'affiche plus les
prix
la situation est pourri
il faut bien s'accrocher
la fin la colère contenue
même parmi les jeunes miliciens de
chavistes certains sont révoltés par
cette situation
[Musique]
david à 23 ans il a voté maduro
dernières élections
c'est terrible j'ai même vu des enfants
pleurer ils disaient mais moi aussi je
veux du pain moi aussi je veux manger
ce sont des enfants qui attendent dans
la file tôt le matin âgé de 8 ans à
peine
et quand le président maduro vous
explique que tout ça c'est à cause du
sabotage de l'opposition vous en pensez
quoi
à la guerre économique écoutez
franchement personne ici ne fait rien
pour améliorer la situation
on arrive bien produire de la nourriture
avec les entreprises d'état alors s'il
fabrique de la farine et qu'ils offrent
gratuitement à certains
pourquoi tous les magasins ne sont pas
approvisionnés
des doutes et des questions même chez
les partisans
nicolas maduro conscient que le discours
officiel a de plus en plus de mal à
passer décide d'asseoir encore plus son
autorité
en juillet il fait élire une nouvelle
assemblée l'assemblée constituante qui
lui est totalement acquise
l'opposition boycottent les élections
qu'elle qualifie de mascarade des
soupçons de fraude pèsent sur le scrutin
on peut lire sur les murs de cette
nouvelle assemblée
ici nous sommes en territoire tchadien
personne ne doit dire du mal ni de
chavez ni de maduro
esther carreaux et l'une de ses députés
pro maduro
c'est aussi l'une des journalistes de
radio les plus populaires du pays c'est
grâce à elle que nous entrons
exceptionnellement dans ce lieu
d'habitude fermée aux caméras
parmi les élus on croise le fils de
nicolas maduro lui aussi député
et esther le connais très bien
[Musique]
les 545 membres sont tous sans exception
des chavistes le tout premier cercle du
pouvoir actuel
ils sont chargés d'écrire une nouvelle
constitution
premier symbole de cette reprise en main
les médias et c'est le dossier nester
les organes de presse ont été utilisées
à plusieurs reprises comme des armes de
guerre
nous ne voulons pas instaurer davantage
de contrôles mais faire en sorte que ces
contrôles soient plus précis et que les
sanctions soit adaptée aux infractions
quand on incite à la haine à la guerre
quand on fait l'apologie de délits
contre une partie de la population on
doit appliquer des sanctions très
spécifiques
notre loi est imparfaite et les médias
comme dirait la bible ont commis des
péchés terrible
deux radios vient d'être ce jour-là
couper des ondes par le gouvernement
officiellement leur licence arrivait à
expiration
depuis le début de l'année une
quarantaine de médias ont été interdits
une mise au pas qui ne pose aucun
problème à leicester elle anime une
émission tous les matins dans l'une des
principales radios du pays et c'est
d'ailleurs comme cela que cette mère de
famille s'est fait connaître auprès du
président maduro en portant la voix du
régime
le thème du jour les manoeuvres
militaires décidée par le président
maduro en réponse aux sanctions
économiques annoncées par les états unis
à l'encontre du venezuela
qu'est ce qui vous a choqué dans les
propos diffusés par les deux radios qui
vient d'être interdite
par exemple il y a eu des positions qui
étaient clairement favorable à l'entrée
de troupes étrangères dans le pays
tout particulièrement de soldats
américains
certaines sous forme de blague
mais comme on dit ici au venezuela à
trop jouer avec le feu on finit par se
brûler
dans notre pays je pense que c'est
inacceptable on peut toujours donner son
opinion mais pas inciter directement à
ce que des troupes étrangères
interviennent dans notre pays
sans état d'âme elle restreint chaque
jour un peu plus la liberté d'expression
l'assemblée constituante accusent tous
ceux qui ont soutenu les récentes
sanctions américaines d'être des
traîtres à la patrie
[Musique]
les nuits à caracas sont devenues
dangereuses pour les voix discordantes
en août dernier le maire de caracas est
arrêté en pleine nuit et en pyjama par
les services secrets bolivarien
ils sont en train d'enlever ledesma
[Applaudissements]
elle incite est une dictature
[Musique]
pour avoir autorisé les manifestations
antonio ledesma 62 ans est aujourd'hui
assigné à résidence
tout comme leopoldo lopez le leader du
principal parti de droite condamné lui à
13 ans de prison
sa femme liliane tintori s'est vu
récemment interdire sa sortie du
venezuela
parmi les dernières cibles les militants
de droite à la tête des cortèges durant
les manifestations
[Musique]
javier chirinos 28 ans est l'un d'entre
eux il fait partie du parti conservateur
veint est un des partis d'opposition qui
défend une ligne ultra libérale
pour avoir monté des barricades il vient
de passer trente trois jours derrière
les barreaux il sort tout juste de
prison
et revient pour la première fois au
siège de son parti
[Musique]
c'est avec ces jeunes militants qu'il a
participé à toutes les grandes
manifestations ces derniers mois
après son arrestation personne n'a eu de
nouvelles de lui pendant plusieurs jours
alors quoi de neuf on travaille bien sur
ces jeunes se range derrière celle que
l'on surnomme la dame de fer
vénézuélienne maria corina machado leur
leader elle est connue pour sa proximité
avec l'administration américaine de
l'ancien président george bush
les chavistes la désigne l comme tous
les membres de son parti comme des
fascistes qui veulent prendre le pouvoir
par la force
l'arrestation de javier est un premier
signe d'avertissement
c'était une cellule de deux mètres sur
trois il y avait 40 personnes entassées
certaines étaient debout avec les pieds
gonflés elle ne pouvait même pas dormir
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de place pour
s'allonger et j'étais détenue avec des
prisonniers de droit commun
les prisonniers politiques sont avec des
meurtriers des violeurs des kidnappeurs
bien sûr ça t'affecte
ils cherchent à nous briser
psychologiquement ou qu'on ne puisse
plus se battre
plus de 700 manifestants ont été déférés
devant les tribunaux militaires c'est ce
que dénonce l'organisation de défense
des droits de l'homme human rights watch
le régime lui justifie les
incarcérations pour lui les manifestants
sont des conspirateurs
à vos adversaires qui disent que vous
êtes d'extrême droite que vous êtes
dangereux que leur répondez vous
c'est sûr on n'est pas socialiste nous
voulons un pays une économie de libre
marché
qu'il y ait des opportunités de
développement pour tout le monde qu'il
n'y ait pas de restriction de contrôle
nous sommes des libéraux
[Musique]
mais attention un libéralisme qui
respecte les citoyens de ce pays
rappelez vous que ces 18 dernières
années les gouvernements de maduro et de
chavez ne respectez pas les citoyens ils
n'ont rien fait pour l'amélioration de
leurs conditions
ils ont tout fait pour les maintenir
dans une précarité économique pour mieux
les contrôler
c'est le propre des systèmes
totalitaires
nous ne voulons pas nous radicaliser
mais si cela signifie défendre ses
convictions et agir pour éviter encore
davantage de morts alors oui nous sommes
des radicaux
javier doit depuis se présenter chaque
mois au tribunal et il a interdiction de
quitter la capitale
son parti a toujours une existence
légale fonctionne mais jusqu'à quand
[Musique]
cette répression systématique de
l'opposition chante même aujourd'hui
certains de chavistes historique un
homme qui a été au coeur du pouvoir a
accepté de nous rencontrer dans un
immeuble discret de la capitale
sa famille est à l'abri à une heure de
caracas car depuis six mois il est
menacé d'arrestation
c'est un général à la retraite
un dissident cleaver alcala
il a été l'un des compagnons de route
d'hugo chavez le président maduro le
considère maintenant comme un traître
à 56 ans je ne peux pas échapper une
femme et lunettes
ce journal roule pour le gouvernement
celui ci aussi et celui ci
le seul journal d'opposition titre la
constitution est bafouée et c'est vrai
nous n'avons plus de constitution elle
est totalement bafoués
ce militaire de carrière connaissez hugo
chavez depuis les années 70 une longue
amitié qui ne l'empêchent pas de
critiquer aujourd'hui le président
maduro
[Musique]
nos prisons sont pleines de vénézuéliens
que l'on a mis là au seul motif qu'il
pense différemment ils ont manifesté et
quelle que soit la manière le droit de
manifester est garantie par notre
constitution
mais c'est pourtant hugo chavez lui-même
qui a demandé aux vénézuéliens de voter
pour mado
oui mais parce que chavez ne savais pas
dans quoi ils s'engageaient il s'est
trompé totalement
il ya aujourd'hui un recul gigantesque
de la démocratie à cause de la mise en
place d'un gouvernement extrêmement
autoritaire et qui le devient chaque
jour un peu plus
mais ce qui a poussé le général alcala
entré en dissidence c'est la corruption
endémique du régime selon les
témoignages d'anciens ministres
chavistes entre 100 et 300 milliards de
dollars auraient été volés par les
proches du pouvoir ces quinze dernières
années il est certain que la corruption
a toujours existé au venezuela elle n'a
pas été créée par ce gouvernement
cela fait longtemps qu'elle se pratique
ici
mais l'ampleur que cela a pris ces
quatre dernières années c'est brutal
et parler de cela ce que je fais
ouvertement c'est prendre un risque pour
sa vie dans ce pays
tout indique que nous vivons dans une
dictature et c'est de pire en pire
chaque jour
mais ça ne vous fait pas peur de parler
comme ça
j'ai fait ça toute ma vie et vous voulez
que je change maintenant que je suis
vieux
c'est comme ça que je parle à thales et
on se respecter mutuellement
[Musique]
des figures historiques qui se
désolidarise
et des proches du régime qui quittent
même le navire
comme l'ex procureur général luisa
ortega qui a dû fuir le venezuela après
avoir critiqué ouvertement le
gouvernement de nicolas maduro
elle aussi était une chavistes convaincu
du président
ils veulent dissimuler les preuves de la
corruption
et les violations des droits de l'homme
commises dans ce pays je vais continuer
à les dénoncer
elle est aujourd'hui réfugié à
l'étranger mais tous les opposants n'ont
pas la chance de pouvoir fuir le pays
voici le quartier de los verdès une
résidence populaire de caracas favorable
à l'opposition
les habitants vivent dans la peur depuis
le mois de juillet dernier
parce qu'ils ont ouvertement soutenu les
manifestations policiers militaires et
miliciens ont envahi leurs immeubles en
représailles depuis leurs fenêtres ils
ont filmé la source
quatorze personnes ont été arrêtées sans
motif puis relâché
nathalie et son amie christina gère la
copropriété elles ont vu de quoi le
régime étaient capables
ils sont entrés par là et sont allés
jusqu'au bout de ce côté horrible
c'était horrible et comment ils sont
entrés
ils ont défoncé les grilles et comme la
voie était libre ceux qui venaient à
pied sont passés par là
il descendait les escaliers en criant
ouvrait les portes nous allons vous
violez vous tuer ouvrez les portes on
casse tout et comme ça ils ont obligé
les gens à tout ouvrir
comme tous les habitants ni meubles
nathalie vit aujourd'hui dans la peur de
leur tour
une fois que tu es ficher les problèmes
commencent
cette comptable subit aujourd'hui
l'essence même d'une dictature
la crainte partagée par des milliers de
vénézuéliens de se faire arrêter du jour
au lendemain sans raison
mon frère a déjà quitté le venezuela à
cause de ce gouvernement
il me dit que je devrais demander
l'asile politique
tous les vénézuéliens devrait demander
l'asile politique combien ça déjà partie
parce que nous n'avons pu devenir
plus de 3 millions de vénézuéliens
aurait déjà quitté le pays dix pour cent
de la population par peur par nécessité
par choix victime de la crise et de la
répression
un exil sans précédent
reste les fidèles comme grégory qui
s'accrochent encore à l'idéal socialiste
d'hugo chavez
quatre années après sa mort le
commandant veille toujours
mais il laisse derrière lui un pays plus
que jamais divisée
[Musique]